me derrumbo para las relaciones entre
arabia saudita y eeuu
ya leyó el informe llama al show de la
inteligencia nacional sí lo he hecho
gracias el miércoles el presidente yo
bailén confirmó que había leído un
informe de inteligencia estadounidense
que pronto será desclasificados sobre el
asesinato de llamar a sergi en 2018
el periodista saudita ingresó al
consulado de su país en estambul el 2 de
octubre de ese año
poco después fue asesinado por un equipo
de agentes vinculados al príncipe
heredero mohamed bin salman el informe
original en el que la cia fue el
principal contribuyente determinó que el
príncipe heredero había ordenado
personalmente el asesinato sin embargo
bajo la administración de donald trump
nunca se presentó evidencia ni se habló
públicamente del tema tal vez lo hizo
tal vez no lo hizo no hicieron esa
evaluación la cia lo ha examinado lo han
estudiado mucho pero no tienen nada
definitivo la semana pasada la casa
blanca informó que ya estaba en marcha
un ajuste de las relaciones entre ambos
países con el presidente de byd en
restableciendo directamente la
comunicación con el rey salman a
diferencia de trump que se había
alineado
el príncipe el presidente está adoptando
un enfoque nuevo sobre cómo se relaciona
con los líderes extranjeros en todo el
mundo y es diferente de la
administración anterior esto significa
que no se contendrá y hablara cuando
haya preocupaciones que tenga sobre los
abusos de los derechos humanos la falta
de libertad de expresión de libertad de
prensa o de cualquier inquietud que
tengas al mismo tiempo tenemos una larga
relación con arabia saudita los
acontecimientos recientes ya apuntan a
un cambio dinámico en la diplomacia
bailén anunció el fin de todo el apoyo
de eeuu a las operaciones ofensivas de
arabia saudita en yemen después de más
de seis años de intercambio de
inteligencia y armas así como apoyo
logístico